[Music]
as tall as the Statue of Liberty more
powerful than anything built since the
days of the lunar landings NASA's new
mega rocket will open new frontiers mr.
Bronstein in an interview with Sky News
the new NASA chief appointed by
President Trump said the first missions
would pick up where Apollo left off
nearly 50 years ago but with a bolder
vision here's what we're doing different
and this comes directly from the
president's space policy directive he
wants us to go to the moon in a
sustainable way meaning this time when
we go we're going to stay we have
ignition and liftoff NASA wants private
companies to take over the International
Space Station freeing it to focus
resources on building a base orbiting
the moon and by the late 2030s a mission
to Mars you may have noticed that the
president likes to do big things and he
wants to do big things
staying in low-earth orbit for the next
20 years using taxpayer funds is not his
idea of the next big thing he wants to
do the next thing the new boss was once
a climate skeptic but he's now seen
enough images of melting ice caps to
change his mind I don't disagree at all
with the scientific consensus NASA has
put out reports saying that it is likely
that humans are the primary cause and I
don't I don't disagree with that
assessment but does president Trump try
to shape the message in any way to to
make sure that it aligns with his own
views not at all never never once have I
heard him suggest that but have you
tried to influence him then because he
is a vocal skeptic on humans and climate
change I've never you know brought it up
to him specifically this is you know
I've been on the job for nine weeks for
the NASA boss the wonder of the solar
system is an opportunity to leave behind
the political rivalry of Earth
deep-space exploration can only be done
together Thomas More Sky News